and symbols and better machinery
okay well thank you so much thank you
Lolita for organizing this Thank You
Adam for the support and today I'm going
to talk about information theory
intersection with fare machine learning
hopefully convince you that this
intersection gives you a set that is
non-empty and the goal of the talk today
is that if you're an information
theories in the room - maybe motivate
you to look at some of the tools in
problems in fare machine learning and if
you're interested in this area to maybe
take a look at some some of what
information through a hash offer and it
gives you say it can give you some
fundamental insight in fairness so the
results that I'm going to talk about
today were mostly done by this amazing
group of people here like a lot of the
results were done by Lisa was a student
at the Harvard College Sean and how PhD
students Burk who is a postdoc at Circus
and Salman who's a grad student at MIT
and in the latter half of the talk a lot
of the results were done with my amazing
collaborators at IBM Denis Koosh Karthi
and Bono and here's agenda for today I'm
going to start with a brief motivation
for fairness I think I might be
preaching to the choir here I know a lot
of people in this room are interested in
this problem but if you already heard
this just sit back relax and enjoy this
time after lunch to hear something good
you know then I'm going to talk about a
few words on modeling and assumptions
and some of the temptations that
information theorists might have when
you're working on this problem this is
something I throw my grad students then
I'm going to define some group fairness
metrics how do we measure fairness in
practice this is one collection of
metrics to do that then talk about the
meat of this talk which is the role of
local perturbations in understanding
bias and correcting for discrimination
which is somewhat connected to rate
distortion theory and finally conclude
with some final remarks so let me start
with a brief motivation for fairness and
why I find this problem an important
problem to look at 30 learning
algorithms are increasingly used in
applications of significant individual
level consequence applications such as
recidivism prediction personal finance
things like ultimately credit scoring
loan approval and so on and things like
employment decisions and hiring
decisions like what zip recruiter does
when you're matching job seekers and job
hires and in the
applications a natural question to ask
is do these algorithms discriminate on
race gender or some other legally
protected attribute and why do we care
about this question well hopefully not
only because all of us want to live in a
more fair and equitable society but also
because it's the law if you're a grad
student here and tomorrow you go on and
do your amazing new startup that's doing
I know AI for human resources or
something like that the United States
legislation has very clear norms of what
constitutes or not constitutes
discrimination and just to be clear
whenever I say discrimination in this
talk I mean it not in its usual
statistical sense but in its social
science sense discrimination has a
prejudicial treatment of an individual
based on membership in a protected group
such as race or gender
and unfortunately machine learning
algorithms can discriminate a simple
example of this apparently Google
changed this recently but until recently
you could go to Google Translate and
type in XI as a doctor he has a nurse
translated to Turkish which is a
gender-neutral language it doesn't have
gender pronouns get that translation and
translate it back to English you will
get he as a doctor she is a nurse why
does this happen well hopefully it
happens not because the software
engineers who developed this application
are somehow biased but probably because
the machine learning algorithms that
underlie Google Translate picked up
biases that exists in the training data
and are now propagating those biases at
the output and this bias propagation is
particularly concerning when you look at
applications such as recidivism
prediction should be in the United
States and many counties if you're
charged with a crime they're gonna take
you to the police station fill a
questionnaire with dozens of questions
about you and feed it to an algorithm
that will give you a score which is what
is the chance that you're going to be
civilized in the near future or not and
recently there was a much debated by the
way article by ProPublica that
identified certain patterns of biases
and some of these algorithms and
discrimination by machine learning has
been documented in many other cases
things like facial recognition natural
language processing and so on so why do
we observe this discriminatory behavior
so one potential option for this is what
is known as disparate treatment and I'm
going to take this slide I already
introduced some of the notation that
we're going to be using in this talk
which is related to the notation that we
saw
earlier this morning so you have a
machine learning model okay you have
this model and you have a set of
legitimate decision variables I'm going
to use as an example recidivism
prediction things like age and criminal
history and you also have a protected
attribute s s here stands for sensitive
and if you use this attribute directly
as an input to your model should produce
an outcome Y hat you have what is known
as disparate treatment right because
your output explicitly depends on the
sensitive attribute more pervasive
nowadays is what is known as disparate
impact where X where s is not used
directly as an input to the model but
features that are correlated with us or
used as an input and it might lead to a
different performance of your model
conditioned on different groups okay
just you make this a little bit more
clear what this means is that condition
on S right condition on your sensitive
attribute majority minority or majority
group for example the distribution of
input features changes and this change
in input distribution might lead to a
difference in performance of your model
yeah it's not just difference in
features right if I if I just output
like no on all people it could also be
disparate impact yeah it could be that
is all this is yeah so and I think
that's natural needs to the next
question so how would you measure this
right and usually it's measured in terms
of a difference and average performance
between your true your predicted outcome
Y hat and the true outcome Y where this
two outcome Y is something that you
don't control it's given by society it's
given by this channel here P of Y given
X and s I'll have more to say how we
measure this layer
so the goal of this talk is to introduce
a few concepts that might be useful in
fairness and maybe interpretability of
these models okay so from if you give me
a model the question that we want your
answer from the interpretability
perspective is why does this model
discriminate can you understand a little
bit more of why we might be observing
bias at the output and use this
information to feed it back and ask how
can I correct for discrimination for a
given model and what I'm going to do
today is present a few information
theoretic ideas that might be common
across applications and use cases that
connect these two problems okay and just
to make this transition a little bit
less jarring from privacy to fairness so
the Lisa already mentioned this this
morning
both setups are of course in practice
very different privacy and fairness they
have different laws that guide them
different consequences in terms of user
experience and things like that
but within this very simple model that
we'll be looking at if you squid you
might be able to see that similar
mathematical tools can be used in both
cases right and privacy we have the
private feature and that was correlated
with your data and your goal should
design this blue box here for which your
disclosure so that you produced this
closed data and on the fairness set up
as is your protected attributes that is
correlated with your data that your
feature machine learning model plus
a-hat here you get the decision and in
both cases you want your Y right your
output should be somewhat invariant to
changes on the underlying s right and
privacy you want Y to not carry much
information about s however you met
measure that and in fairness you want
the performance of this model should not
change conditioned on s okay so we're
going to be talking about fairness and
before I move on I just want to say a
few words on modeling and assumptions
and add a disclosure before I go on with
the rest of the talk and this is
something I share with my graduate
students when they're thinking of
working in this area so right here we
have an information three cat you can
think about this as a graduate student
who is really excited about information
theory or postdoc who's thinking about
new problems should work with well how
do you know it's an information theory
cat well how do you know that this cat
likes and for
in theory well because it's really
excited about capacity results suggest
that you scale divergence for everything
for any problem that you have and it
goes on these long tangents about phase
transition phenomena and coding problems
and then insists on wearing that free
t-shirt that it got from ITA from many
years back and the information theorists
understand that joke and well this
information three cat now wants to work
with fair machine learning right and
like most information theorists this cat
lives in this Schroedinger like state in
between theory and practice
right and the theory of information
theory is a theory of well-defined
models and abstractions it's a world of
probability distributions and measurable
things
iid samples precise metrics and well
defined groups clean data what
computational assumptions right and so
on but the truth is when working in fair
machine learning especially from the
practical personal side you have to take
care because the practice is messy right
when you talk about fairness and bias
we're talking about things like that
Dutch legislation and public policy
individual level experiences the way
people experience discrimination might
be very different things like implicit
biases the groups that you're trying to
protect against discrimination might be
fluid overlapping and hard to define
data is messy and often and often small
like you might be observing bias because
of hard to identify causal relationships
the distribution that you use during
training time changes when you apply
your model and test time and so on right
so these roles are very different and
one has to take care when you're trying
to reconcile both of them but whenever I
think about this this is a slide that
using gas in class I think about a quote
by David slapping this is was from his
Shannon Award lecture his second he was
the second Shannon Award winner the
first Shannon Award winner beam well
Shannon and we're yeah right and and
where he there he calls Theory facet a
and practice facet B I'm not sure me
well during his lecture he says should
the extent that there is some
correspondence between facets a and B we
have the miracle of modern science the
deepening understanding of our universe
and the bounty and ease of the
technological society in which we live
and I think the best part is the of his
lectures one of the best parts is the
second part of this quote where he says
a second-order miracle a little
recognized or appreciated is that this
miracle could arise from a really ragged
bit between both facets okay so you know
the theory and practice of fair machine
learning there is there there is a
challenge and reconciling both views
both facets I will claim that
information three has then this brother
successfully and other errors and things
like communications for example but and
now what I'm going to give you is just a
few very few information three tools
that might be useful in fair machine
learning it but I proceed like I just
want to put this caveat here they're
like well aware that the practice of
discrimination bias is very messy it's
complicated
but nevertheless hopefully in the next
few minutes the next half an hour so I
can convince you that some information
theory perspective can help understand
something fundamental about this problem
okay so yeah let's plow ahead here so a
first natural question is how do you
measure fairness mathematically how can
you quantify these things all right and
the metrics that we're going to be using
is something known as a group fairness
metric that seeks to quantify this
disparate impact so let's return to the
model that I introduced in the beginning
of the talk ok so we have our legitimate
input variables X you have a sensitive
attribute s s is not used directly as an
input to your model but X is and in
order to produce an outcome y hat the
try to approximate the true outcome wife
right and let's assume you have a
disparate impact you observe a different
difference in performance when you
measure when you input samples from one
population versus the other population
so group fairness metrics are usually
defined in terms of differences between
outcomes and error rates across the
different populations okay so let me
give you a recipe on how to build these
so-called group fairness metrics that
are used in the fair machine learning
literature and this is based on an
excellent tutorial the arvind narayan
gave at fat star a couple of years ago
so assume that why in my header is
binary
okay the simplest case
I can dip my model and I can feed
samples from population s equals zero
think about that as the minority
population and build this confusion
matrix here the true negative false
positive false negative is negative rate
and true positive rate and also look at
the marginals right what is the fraction
of that population that I'm marking as Y
hat equals one like what is the fraction
of the population that I'm marking as
recidivist I can go and do the exact
same thing for the majority population s
equals one and if you're comparing for
example the difference of of inputs that
you mark as Y hat equals one right this
is what is called statistical parity
when you try to equalize these two
numbers you can try to equalize for
example false positive and true positive
rates and then you get something that is
known as equalizer in the literature
proposed by a heart price and that is
several where you're trying to condition
on the true outcome being one or zero or
do you want the probability of marking Y
hat equals one should be approximately
the same across both populations if you
restrict you this box here you get
something known as Zuko opportunity
where you're just looking at the the
true outcomes where the true output is y
equals one but however you split it
there are common Authority many metrics
that you can define just by combining
and comparing these truth tables and
there's many trade offs that you can
drive between these different fairness
metrics and in fact there's like quite a
few results in the literature fair
machine learning that seek to understand
trade-offs between these metrics and
what we're going to do today what we're
going to do next is ask a very simple
question which is how do these metrics
change when the underlying distributions
are perturbed okay if I were to
hypothetically change a little bit the
distribution over one of the groups it's
just a thought experiment how would that
influence your metric and that will say
something interesting about potential
sources of bias and how we can correct
for that so this is what we're going to
do next and then next we're going to
look at the role of perturbations and
understanding bias and here we're going
to be using tools that are found in
robust statistics and also in something
called opinion information three where
you look at small perturbations of
measures and see how that might help us
understand disparate impact
is it clear what we're doing next
perturb things is it known just how to
construct hypothesis test to satisfy
those different I'll say that towards
and like how can you change a mod or
process or destroy your data and so on
and that will be the part five like
correcting for discrimination so let's
put that question on hold and go get
there any other questions
but I just should be clear in the answer
yeah there are several methods to do
that and we'll be talking about that in
a bit okay so but you look at these
perturbations before we perturb things
this is these are this is the framework
that I'm going to consider I'm going to
make three key assumptions okay so the
first assumption is that we have a
classifier and this classifier is a
black box I don't care how this
classifier is implemented you can think
about this as an API that I feed samples
should that classifier and I get results
back okay um this classifier is denoted
as H of X it's not an it doesn't depend
on your sensitive attribute explicitly
you can think about this as a doubt put
of a classifier being a belief a
probability distribution we have y hat
equals X second assumption is that I'm
going to assume that I have an auditing
data set right this classifier is there
it's implemented and I have a data set
some that is sampled from the deployment
population where I want you apply that
classifier if I don't have such a data
set it might even be hard to identify
biases in this model and so on okay so
for example this auditing data set in
the recidivism prediction case might be
something with samples of race age per
count degree charge and recidivism for
your underlying population and I'm going
to assume that s and Y are binary just
for the sake of simplicity for the rest
of the talk okay and so first we have a
black box model second we have an
auditing data set the third assumption
that we're going to make is that we have
a fairness metric as I mentioned there
are many the fairness metrics that we're
going to consider are based on the on
the metrics that I presented in the
comparison of true positive and true and
false positive rates and just you
introduce some notation this this first
one is looks like statistical parity I'd
use the scale divergence this one was
proposed by the information theory cat
and and we're going to assume that we
have a target group who has a unfavorite
performance you're observing a higher C
false positive rate or something like
that and you have a baseline group over
which you want to normalize the
performance for right and we're good to
make so the target group you're going to
mark it as s equals zero can think about
some minority group or of this favorite
group and rigor to assume that py given
X as the model that produces this
this the true outcomes is fixed that the
distribution of features over the
baseline group is fixed and that the
prior P of s is fixed as well so
assuming that all of these things are
fixed you can cast these metrics in
terms of one parameter well in terms of
one distribution which is the
distribution over the baseline group and
what we're going to do next is a thought
experiment it's not something that we
can actually go and do in practice but
it's just a thought experiment you see
where it takes us
that we're going to ask how can we find
a new distribution over the target group
that minimizes a given disparity metric
and by the way all the results that I'm
going to present now also can take into
account the linear combinations between
these metrics so that gives you things
like equalized odds and and so on okay
so this is a thought experiment that
we're going to do and I'm going to
introduce this through a picture okay so
what this boot triangle here represents
is a probability simplex just a cartoon
that illustrates the space of all
possible distributions over input
futures the distribution of your target
group will be a point here P of X given
s equals 0 over your baseline group yeah
of x given s equals 1 and if you were to
sample from each of these populations it
when do sub output distribution either
over the predicted outcomes or over the
true outcomes or if you sample from P of
X given s equals 0 feed it to a
classifier you get a distribution
induced over outputs and the same thing
for the true distribution simply for P
of x given s equals 1 so our goal is
that we want you to change this
distribution to start this distribution
in order to reduce the disparity over
the group s equals 0 in the group that's
unfavorite right
maybe you'll you'll get to this later
but why is the interest like what I'm
not sure is it the fact that we're gonna
think of this as some operation we can
perform in real life yeah so let me let
me explain so where this is going we're
going to analyze this theoretically and
then we're going to see that the
solution of this we can actually find
these distributions that minimizes
return back to just by doing
combinations of models and then we're
going to use that to solve an
optimization problem in order to reduce
disparity so our ultimate goal is to
change the classifier no the classifiers
fixed regrets you're pre-process the
data before we change the classifier but
for furn unit yeah okay yeah sure create
a new classifier which happens to work
by like first doing something yes yes
and so your goal what like what is the
actual what is it what is the problem
you're actually you're sort of
ultimately aiming to solve maybe is the
question yeah so my my goal should
understand like how to find this
distribution and later on map points
from this distribution into this new
distribution basically create a
preprocessor for my my group s equals 0
before I feed so yeah
I feel like that's an intermediate goal
like you're trying to commit but maybe I
don't understand
she trying to find a new classifier yeah
it just does better with respect to
particular exactly on this particular
distribution yes okay yeah and now the
weight specifically you want to do that
is by pre-processing you're gonna you
know do something to get to the input
features so that this ya better you know
this particular metric you fixed any
other questions yeah yeah we're gonna
randomized it and later on I'm gonna use
that as a segue to pre-processing
methods in discrimination prevention of
which there are many like our
intervention mechanisms yeah I guess I
was gonna ask for figured you get to is
like there are lots of proposed ways to
yeah and I'll get there absolutely yeah
all right yeah I'll get there anything
else
okay good so again so we're looking at
these perturbations because eventually
we want to understand how to correct for
bias alright and maybe be able to
identify something interesting about why
we are observing this disparate impact
and maybe see something about that so
we're going to call the set of these
distributions that minimize a given
disparity metric as we're going to name
them counterfactual distributions this
is a loaded term so we use the term
counterfactual because it's the sense of
thinking what would be the distribution
over this group in order to remove a
given disparity metric right but again
the contractual dis term is used in many
different ways and calls of inference
and so on but all that it means here is
that this is a set of distributions that
minimizes a given disparity metric when
you change the distribution over the
minority group or the target group in
order to one of the distributions in
this set and you might be wondering well
why do I just map this distribution
entry on true P of x given s equals one
right why do I make the distribution
over the target group the same as the
baseline group well that's not
necessarily optimal if you're looking at
things like false positive rates or true
positive rates and so on because this
channel here P of Y given X s we're
assuming that it's fixed
gahafer just looking at statistical
parity where you want to equalize the
output distributions you will map this
blue dot onto this green dot here okay
so next up good you see how you can find
these counterfactual distributions via
local perturbations and later on I'm
going to show how you can use it to do a
pre-processing mechanism in order to
remove this Ritt impact for a given
metric and then mention about other
methods that do that as well okay so you
can find this counterfactual
distributions via local perturbations
you can think about that as gradient
descent over the probability space and
layer I'm going to show you how you can
actually instantiate this in practice
okay so if your grad student in the room
and this is a cool thing to know how do
you prepare probability distribution so
that you stay on the simplex and the way
you can perturb it is usually instead of
adding an additive perturbation the
easiest way of doing it is that in a
multiplicative perturbation as long as
this function has finite variance in
zero mean a when measured according to P
of X given s equals zero
you're still on the simplex okay so as
long as this function has room you know
according to P of X you have an s equals
zero and when you perturb your
distribution like this the output
distribution also has a multiplicative
form so we can also write output
distribution as P of Y given s equals 0
x 1 plus epsilon G of Y where this G is
simply the conditional expectation of F
given Y ok so this perturbation is
mapped into this perturbation via the
conditional expectation operator so just
to make this clear you write your you're
looking at multiplicative perturbations
over the distribution of your minority
group of your target group and that maps
into a multiplicative this perturbation
of the output assuming that these
functions are in the space of 0 mean
finite variance functions of each of
these distributions you can look at the
spectrum of the conditional expectation
operator and understand how the
perturbation of one input distribution
affects the output and overall effects
your metrics and I'll have a lot more to
say about the the spectrum of this guy
here and conditioned on s equals 0 is
missing tomorrow during the privacy talk
okay so I just wanted to put a
placeholder here please come tomorrow
and learn more about it but for now
we're going to do this local
perturbation in this mode multiplicative
form then we're going to call the new
perturb distribution as P tilde time of
your original distribution times 1 plus
epsilon f of X okay so and which
perturbation should we choose well we're
going to do something that looks like a
derivative right we're going to perturb
according to the direction that
minimizes a given disparity metric so
when you write these things like this
this looks like a derivative in the
probability space right it's directly
these local perturbations this is a tool
that you find for example in obedient
information 3 these are some tools that
were used in network information theory
and so on this is also connected to
influence functions in robust statistics
right what an influence functions asks
is how would this statistic change your
disparity metric if you were to add just
a little bit of probability mass onto
your distribution you can think about
this as having a very very long day
large data
set and how would that metric change if
you were to change one sample of that
data set and recent paper we show that
the the function that minimizes overall
functions F that minimizes your
disparity metric the direction of
steepest descent is equivalent to a
normalized version of the influence
function so the question of trying to
find this counterfactual distributions
find in a hypothetical distribution that
would minimize a given disparity metric
then is mapped to computing these
influence functions from data and how do
you compute these influence functions
for different fairness metrics my frame
like zero zero mean over what so if your
mean over P of X given s equals zero
because if this function has zero mean
this whole thing still adds up to one
when you integrate over X and as long as
you're making absalom smaller anyways
but as long as it has finite variance is
you're also trying to ensure that this
doesn't become negative when you perturb
so you're still stuck on the simplex
so again just rephrasing but I just said
like you're asking how would you perturb
the probability distribution so that the
resulting perturbed thing is also still
a valid probability distribution after
that you can restrict theft you have 0
mean and find it variance unit variance
because you're making epsilon very small
anyways yes sir I see where 0 being
comes in an orange and Y now thank you
yeah I'm not sure I understand why
variance is this is just a restriction
that we added you don't have to restrict
variance to be one but since we're
making epsilon small anyways and you can
just normalize everything but that's not
a necessary condition but it comes in
down the next slide because you're
you're you're picking your normalizing
the the size function in this specific
way yeah yeah because here we're
restricting a minimization should have
unit variance and that's what we're
doing you don't have to you can always
have a multiplicative constant here
because you're making this epsilon small
anyways
maybe you can talk more about that later
okay okay so this is the expression for
the influence functions they're really
complicated expressions I'm not going to
go into details here you can find their
relations and our recent preprint but
this is the takeaway of how you would
compute these things from data okay like
you're trying to find what would be this
hypothetical distribution that would
remove discrimination you have you can
all what these complicated expressions
indicate is that you can estimate this
influence function by three steps first
is that you train a blackbox classifier
you have your club blackbox classifier
that you're auditing you can train a new
classifier locally right based on your
auditing dataset that try should predict
group membership given your samples X
and you create a new classifier that
approximates the just for your baseline
group right you try to create this row
calibrated classifier P of Y given X s
equals 0 and by these are values that
you can estimate from your auditing data
set and based on that you can compute
the influence functions that I showed on
the previous you can plug these values
into these equations and you can
estimate the influence functions and how
do you recover a counterfactual
distribution well we never actually
recovered the distribution itself we're
not going to get an expression for this
distribution what we're going to get is
a set of resampling rates for your for
your for your distribution over the
minority group a set of your sampling
weights for your auditing data set
condition over your target group so that
if you were to be sample according to
that those weights you will get
something that approximates the
counterfactual distribution and in order
to recover it you can do something like
so casick gradient descent on oops sorry
gradient descent on the simplex where
you have a point
you estimate the influence function you
compute the perturb distribution and you
get a new distribution resample you're
auditing data set according to these new
weights and perturb it estimate the
influence functions again and just keep
doing that
and eventually you arrive at this set of
distributions that minimizes disparate
impact and you can actually do this in
practice right so you can actually go
and resample
this is just one example using
artificial data we have more examples in
our paper where as you compute these
influence functions and keep estimating
and you can actually arrive at a loose
set of weights across your auditing data
set when you resample according to those
weights and feed it to the classifier
that disparity is removed so yeah so
maybe in the recidivism data set it's
very large as you mean zero is black for
example then you are going to sample
less yeah well the question is how can
use this for model repair and I'm going
to give you one way of using this for
motive you've heard there are many
methods for trying to remove the
discrimination from your model and using
this counterfactual distribution and the
way you can do this is I'm just to make
our goal clear right what I mean by
model repair is a set of methods called
pre-processing methods where here's your
black box classifiers you have samples
from one group and samples from another
group and your goal should design
something that looks like this the
classifier is still here but you can
locally change your sample all right so
that before you feed it to the
classifier you might when you look at
the average output of the classifier you
reduce disparity but now we have a
original distribution and we have this
target counterfactual distribution how
do we map samples from one distribution
to the other
you can solve an optimal transport
problem for example and the optimal
transport problem gives you a coupling
that you can you can use to build this
preprocessor right where this costs to
try to control so that you don't distort
your data a lot and you can solve this
optimization problem try to get this
mapping and then build this preprocessor
and for different fairness metrics false
positive rate false negative rates and
so on you can actually you can actually
apply this approach like this is show
examples on the adult data set and the
compass data set where you have the
discrimination gap and you follow this
procedure and after you map it to the
this new distribution using the
randomization given the coupling given
by the solution of your optimal
transport you can actually remove the
discrimination for most cases here
what you were concerned about was this
chart target yeah so this is exactly
what I want to mention now like you see
that the discrimination is removed but
there's some loss of performance here
and classification performance and this
loss is connected to for example the
cost that you choose so the question is
what is the optimal way of do that doing
that and in part yeah is there some
cases where you can't necessarily
completely remove discrimination yeah we
have conditions in the paper where by
following this procedure where the gap
can not necessarily be made zero because
basically your class yeah no because
like it things like false positive rate
for example might be different so we
have conditions in the paper for when
this necessary conditions for this being
0 not sufficient they do so what is the
optimal trade-off between correcting for
discrimination and accuracy right there
are many many other mechanisms that seek
to ensure fairness ok and I would argue
that like determining these optimal
trade-offs is something that is well
within the purview of information
theorists I don't have a solution for
this now but what I want to give you
next is just just to wrap up the talk it
is just a few methods for correcting for
discrimination then not just by myself
by many others so how would you repair a
model right and these methods can be
very roughly classified in terms of
pre-processing and processing and
post-processing ok so here's a set up
and by the way this is a very incomplete
list of references there is many a lot
of work happening in this field so I
just want to put that make that
disclaimer so you have your data set
right and you're feeding it to the model
in order to produce the output y hat
right you may or may not be using your
sensitive attribute Y of course the true
outcome is not used during testing and
and so on so one strategy that you can
do is something similar to what we did
right
processing I'm going to produce a
preprocessor so that I'm going to
somehow they start my data before I use
it for training or before I feed it to
the model in order to ensure symmetric
of fairness
another option zoo in processing where
we changed the model itself in order to
ensure fairness right you might be have
a logistic regression and try to figure
out how to tweak the weights of the
logistic regression or something like
that use some model specific
characteristic and the third option is
post-processing right for example in
this work you can set different
thresholds for different groups and look
at the output of the model if it's
making like soft decisions at different
thresholds for your decisions and so on
and seek to ensure fairness that way so
the tools from rate distortion theory
may help us delineate some of the limits
of data pre-processing for
discrimination prevention right and
might be able to help us answer what is
the optimal trade-off at least in
certain cases where you can where you
know the distribution artificially for
example that you could achieve between
fairness and accuracy so just to make
this clear when you're designing a
preprocessor usually what you're trying
to design is something like this and
these are kinds of things that we see in
privacy all the time right where you
receive a sample sxy and you want you
map it into a new set of samples as X
hat Y hat in order to control
discrimination according to your
favorite metric you also want to limit
individual Distortion right you this a
some may call it a notion of individual
fairness right you want to avoid certain
gross deviations can always achieve
fairness by just producing random
outputs but you want you might be want
to ensure that accuracy is preserved and
you might have so also some notion of
utility I use the term here utility very
loosely all that this means is that if
you're changing the data before you
input through the mall or before your
train the model might want the output
distribution should be similar to the
original one just so that the model that
you learn is not drastically different
sometimes this model is interprete below
your might be able to say something
interesting by by looking at it so when
you have these three goals like maybe
your first reaction is you just fit them
in into an optimization problem and this
is exactly what we did in a prior paper
from a couple of years back together
with collaborator
at IBM where you get a formulation that
looks remarkably similar to the test
channel that you get a rate distortion
theory and so on where if you were to
know this distribution P of X Y you can
try to find this our randomization map
in order to preserve utility limit
individual distortion right control
these deviations that you have and for a
given discrimination metric here I'm not
going to go into the details of what
this J means but you can think about
that as the disco parity for example in
order to change that you reduce this to
control discrimination and if you know
the distribution you can solve this and
should try to receive like what is the
optimal trade-off that you get of course
we may not know the distribution in
practice you can try to solve this using
for example the empirical distribution a
type estimate of your distribution and
see how that works if you use a type to
solve this optimization formulation what
you you can get guarantees that look
like this this is for statistical parity
this is your utility guarantee of course
the distortion is a property of your map
in itself I just wanted to show this
result because you see here that this
convergence bound is not that great it's
pretty terrible actually it depends on
it only holds for discrete data it
depends on the probability of the least
likely symbol and on the size of your
alphabets and so on and take the chance
for advertise in the visa stock where
she's going to talk about more refined
bounds when you're using empirical
estimates for for looking at the
solution for these optimization problems
but you can actually go and design these
rents assuming that your data is not
that big you can go and solve this
optimization problem and get this
distortion mapping and apply it in
practice so again this is another
example with the recidivism prediction
data set the compass data set where if
you get a the compass data set is a data
set with recidivism information about
people that were charged as a crime in
Broward County in Florida and there you
reconsider as the percentage of
attributes race and if you just use that
data set they have the true recidivism
outcomes and use that to train a random
forest classifier to predict recidivism
you get significand use
sensitive attribute as an input to your
model you get fairly good accuracy and
but you also have a lot of these for the
random force that we train you get quite
a bit of discrimination
so there's go the the gap in statistical
priority is pretty high you can do the
same thing just by dropping the
sensitive attribute retrain the model
and see what accuracy achieve you have a
small loss in accuracy but you see you
this real impact is still present here
and these two points here are the the
solution of solving the the previous
optimization problem using different
parameters control parameters and
plugging it in and you can see that you
can reduce discrimination approximately
to the target values of point one and
point zero five and the natural question
to ask is what is the best that you can
do right what would be the optimal
information theoretic limit in this case
and I guess this is more of a call for
action because I don't think we have a
crisp solution for that and in
particular I just want to highlight this
result this paper this is a paper by Sir
of Friedler and collaborators from this
year's fat start conference where they
did a remarkable and great effort and
trying to compare the many different
fairness intervention mechanisms some of
which I cited in the previous slides and
as you can see here this is the test of
these mechanisms for different at
different data sets on the y-axis you
have accuracy on the x-axis you have
something that looks like statistical
parity this is another example that
looks at the same and you see the the
performance of these metrics are all
over the place right I think a natural
question would be is why what would be
the the can we create synthetic datasets
and analyze the distribution of these
datasets using tools from information
theory to ask what would be the best
that you can achieve in terms of these
accuracy discrimination trade-offs
chuckling down here but what is this so
you think my prediction should be
independent of my know yeah disco parity
what it says is like if you look at you
read this you're training a classifier
to predict recidivism and you're asking
that the fraction of recidivist for the
population s equals zero and the
fraction of the population marked as we
said this for s equals one how should be
within a certain value of each other
like point 10% or difference or 5%
difference so let's say you want to be
on the left side like so yeah so again
the takeaway here is that there are a
lot of mechanisms for ensuring fairness
right there are many different
approaches using your own networks using
optimization using other other methods I
think it would be interesting it's
interesting to ask like what is the best
that you will trade-off what is the best
that we can do here what is the
benchmark that we should be aiming for
so I'm going to wrap up with some final
remarks there are many other interesting
questions you're asked in this field for
example there may be other unobserved
Latin variables and potentially causal
factors that may explain the disparity
that you're observing in your model
right these there's a lot of recent work
and trying to understand how can we
input confounding factors into our
analysis
I think another challenging problem is
that that we're looking at as well is
that the disparity in the model output
may be due to lack of samples from the
minority group during training it might
be the case that you're observing this
disparity simply because when you train
that model you then use enough samples
from a given population just you so I
guess quantifying the impact of data
size data set size and diversity on the
bias of machine learning algorithms
that's something that I do think
information theoretic tools could help
this is just one example if you do a
google image search I did this a few
months back for wedding and you're gonna
get a bunch of brides in white dresses
and grooms in a suit which may not
necessarily reflect like the diverse
notions of wedding that we have right so
how can we make sure that our data sets
are diverse enough so if you're
interested in working with fairness and
and testing out some of these algorithms
I do recommend you also looking at the
AI 360 toolbox launched by IBM they have
a very nice package where a lot of the
metrics that I mentioned and a lot of
these fairness intervention mechanisms
are implemented the optimization on the
optimized pre-processing method that I
mentioned is is also there if you want
to try to - yes that one out and I'm
going to end with a slightly cheesy note
which is that with big data comes big
responsibility right responsibility and
privacy fairness and transparency and I
do think information 3 can help alright
I think there's a lot of important it's
fundamental questions that of course it
requires modeling assumptions it might
be a little bit different from practice
but it can reveal some fundamental
insight there might be design driver for
practical algorithms so this is just
some work on this area that's been done
by my group over the past year year and
a half so please take a look again the
code for
this counterfactual distribution thing
is also on github if you want to play
around with it with your own assets and
yeah I think I went there Thanks
[Applause]
regarding the trade-off you mentioned
pakicetus there's I guess if the
distributions are all in gold is the
trade-off well I think the night and I
would say like the naive approach for
that is asking like well what if I just
look at sample by sample like distortion
mechanisms and I solve an optimization
problem in that case if the distribution
is known I can cast it as an
optimization problem and see the
solution and see what the trade-off is I
think the more interesting question is
actually formulated in terms of some
kind of operational formulation right
have a dataset this end samples and I'm
trying to learn some kind of new
representation of that data set so that
when I feed that representation to train
them all over something I just made
something from that representation I can
ensure a certain fairness like
especially if you're using
representations that are something like
a quantization or something like that I
think the other question is like why
would you do pre-processing at all right
the right whenever you just like once
you have a model why when you tweet them
all or somehow tweak the output of the
model and yeah I guess we're going from
this I mean yeah you can imagine they
doing some pre-processing or publishing
or model tweaking the investors imagine
like a clean slate design this is not a
consideration when the model was first
created
so let's thrilled about thinking about
how that salt problem they're really
going to solve at the model but not with
this add a constraint in it and you know
perhaps one place to start with even a
known distribution case you know p PX
given s equals 0 and so on and then I
just let me regulate the ratio test
which is what you do without any kind of
fairness criterion you have some kind of
modified like a ratio test I guess that
would account for that and
and you know better go from there to the
case where you don't know this we should
exactly give samples and kind of
building that but it's all you're saying
this region is known then it's then it's
known college this trade-off between us
so it yeah well that's one way of what
you mentioned by the way there's recent
work by I believe my Gupta and ninety
several and others where they try to add
fairness constraints when you're doing
gradient descent for training a model so
like having models that are fair already
by design so there is definitely some
work in that area so yeah excuse when
the description is known what do the
schemes look like that kind of I think
yeah it depends on the and I think this
is one of the challenges because even
that's why I really applaud the effort
of like of comparing all these different
models because like you look at
different papers sometimes they use
different metrics use different
assumptions
so I had a couple of questions one
technical one done that I don't know how
much time but the technical question was
you mentioned this influence function
like how complicated I didn't understand
in that you had there's like there's
three ingredients you need you know
forget what they were so presumably we
don't know how to approximate how to
optimally classify you know estimate Y
given X and s equals zero and if we did
we wouldn't be H to begin with yeah so
to what extent like how do you deal with
the fact that you're solving these
classification problems you know
themselves or you're solving them like a
proc sir yes perfectly yeah so this is
the reason that we are interested in
this so I guess let me just rephrase
your question to see if I understand it
correctly so the question is like look
you're training this anyways right
you're training a model over your target
group so why why do you care about H of
X at all why don't you just go and use
that model directly fine questions yeah
so the reason is because you can use
this to actually audit the model that
you have so the interesting thing and
this is some analysis that we have in
our paper is that you want to see for
example why am i observing this bias
right then you can look at these
influence functions and aggregate them
over features so for example one thing
that we let me give you a concrete
example of that like so you're doing
recidivism prediction and you know that
one group has four on average a higher
prior counsel than the other group right
and at the same time your model takes
prior con to heavily into account and
producing output decisions right so you
know that that future might be a future
that is a proxy right and you can of
course how can you find this in an
entirely data-driven way and these
influence functions can be used exactly
for that so kind of like to try to
understand why you're observing
this and flag individual features that
might be serving as proxies for for
discrimination and that's actually was
our original motivation and our first
paper that I said to you last your own I
mean they give it a lot of interesting
dates but you know something yes yeah
thanks absolutely this is just an
absolutely super story advice because my
question was like a little different is
like you're not you can't you you don't
expect to be able to solve these
problems perfectly yeah oh I see so we
have bounds on that in the paper as well
so we have bounds of the following form
if yeah if your your pure out of this by
a factor of like some epsilon how does
that affect the error in your influence
functions we have pers some somewhat
precise bounds for that as well so if
you basically the way it works is that
if your error in estimating these
quantities or your I know epsilon away
in terms of total variation how does
that translate to an error in your
influence function itself and we do have
bounds for that we can discuss that
offline
I guess my other question had to do like
you know these different disparity
metrics are not usually consistent
yeah
you know it's not even there they're
kind of questions about that what most
of them look for is to ensure that
errors are distributed in some somewhat
evenly according to some metric across
groups not entirely about fairness but
like what how how do you take into
account the fact that like you're
degrading the performance of the
classifier if the fairness metrics
somehow like suppose the result of this
is that you just make the classifier
less you you know you're showing that
you're the area under your curve for the
the classifier was going down all that
new error is happening on this one group
because that's the only place where
you're changing behavior the classifier
like at that point to what you know how
do you decide how do you think about
whether or not this is actually making
the system that you're worried about the
social system that you worry about more
like there ya know I think that's a
that's a excellent question and I think
that's one of the challenges right
because there are so there are inherent
trade-offs between a lot of these
metrics these metrics are not
independent right by ensuring I know a
better like statistical parity you might
be sacrificing false positive rate
things like that and the question is
then like how can you ensure that if
you're correcting for errors on one kind
you're not adding more errors in terms
of the other kind and that's yeah that's
I don't think I have a concrete like
this is how you solve that problem like
you choose a metric you optimize for
that metric another metric might be
suffering because of it yeah and this is
the nature of these trade-offs
I guess what they depend on who is
deploying it
how they would use it I think the more
interesting thing here also is like that
these influence functions and as well
allow you to probe your model and that's
like what input features might be more
important for assuring equalizer odds
which input futures might be more
important for ensuring as a fiscal
parity and things like that but it under
but yeah I idle for many of these
metrics there's no free lunch
I mean there's a more philosophical
problem if the original data itself is
very skewed I mean and you're doing
social engineering it's like the the the
the heart has had to come up with this
test right I mean it's then they picked
a number it's that 10% had to be woman
on it's 40% so it's just some number
that could be legally motivated in some
way yeah but and I think like all Rome
it maybe it's not the best but our row
and that is kind of like we're the
plumbers behind it right like you you
design the engine of the car you're
design safe airbags but like there's a
lot of questions about what are the
rules of the road right but at the same
time like it's the same thing here like
you try tripping mechanisms that allow
you to navigate trade-offs that you've
good trade-offs between different
metrics and so on and then discuss with
practitioners how you would help how
does it even make sense and choosing an
operating point for them how would you
choose that and so on love you why not
keep you two models one model that is
training to two on minority group and
then another model that is trained to do
well on a majority group yeah I know you
might not have enough data points to
train the model for the minority group
but you could potentially think of ways
of fusing the other data points that
belong to kind of people in the majority
group to train this model yeah but then
you would still have two separate models
and you wouldn't be compromising so when
you're using the information that you
may not may not even be loved are you
gonna use no yeah well I think like I'm
not gonna debate the legality of it like
you can still wind up with very large
disparities according to any number of
nurse like yeah you can
come on yeah it doesn't training
separate models doesn't really solve the
question you know how do you decide if
the pommels you've trained are like okay
yeah and there's even a question like
Kenny can you allow disparate treatment
and order in the sense I can you in this
case does someone identify themselves as
part of a group which I'm sure fairness
in the model like these questions are
can you even do that and some
applications that's something that's
that's questionable so in some cases
they could you can in cases like
medicine for example you can in some
cases like loan approval can't but now
you're doing it in a way to maybe ensure
fairness so would that be okay I know
yeah okay who paid for college admission
that's me in a couple months